we know that an element is defined by
the number of protons it has for example
potassium we look at the periodic table
of elements and i have a snapshot of of
not the entire table but part of it here
potassium has 19 protons and we could
write it like this and this is a little
bit redundant we know that if it's
potassium that atom has 19 protons and
we we know if an atom has 19 protons it
is going to be potassium
now we also know that not all members of
or not all of the atoms of a given
element have the same number of neutrons
and when we talk about a given element
but we have different numbers of
neutrons we call them isotopes of that
element so for example potassium
potassium can come in a form that has
exactly 20 neutrons and we call that
potassium we call that potassium 39. and
the 39 this mass number it's a count of
the 19 protons
19 protons plus 20 neutrons and this is
actually the most common isotope of
potassium it accounts for
93.3 i'm just rounding off this is
93.3 percent of the potassium that you
would find on earth now some of the
other isotopes of potassium you also
have potassium and once again writing
the k and the 19 are a little bit
redundant you also have potassium 41 so
this would have 22 neutrons 22 plus 19
is 41. this accounts for about 6.7
percent of the potassium on the planet
and then you have a very scarce isotope
of potassium called potassium 40.
potassium 40. curly has 21 neutrons and
it's very very very very scarce it
accounts for only
0.0117 percent of all the potassium but
this is also the isotope of potassium
that's interesting to us from the point
of view of dating old old rock and it's
especially old volcanic rock
and as we'll see when you can date old
volcanic rock it allows you to date
other types of rock or other types of
fossils that might be sandwiched in
between old volcanic rock and so what's
really interesting about potassium 40
here is that it has a half-life of 1.25
billion years so the good thing about
that as opposed to something like
carbon-14 it can be used to date really
really really old things and every 1.25
billion years so every 1.25 billion
years let me write it like this
1.25
billion years that's its half-life so 50
of any given sample will have decayed
and 11
11 will have decayed into argon 40.
11 will have decayed into argon 40. so
argon is right over here it has 18
protons so when you see when you think
about it decaying into argon 40 what you
see is that it lost a proton but it has
the same mass number so one of the
protons
must have somehow turned into a neutron
it actually captures one of the inner
electrons and it and then emits other
things and i won't go into all the
quantum physics of it but it turns into
argon 40 and 89
89 turn into calcium 40.
calcium 40 and you see calcium on the
periodic table right over here is 20
protons so this is a situation where one
of the neutrons turns into a protons
this is a situation where one of the
protons turns into a neutron and what's
really interesting to us is this part
right over here
this part right over here because what's
cool about argon and we studied this a
little bit in the chemistry playlist it
is a noble gas it is unreactive and so
when it is when it is embedded in
something that's in a liquid state it'll
kind of just bubble out it's not bonded
it's not bonded to anything and so it'll
just bubble out and just go out into the
atmosphere so what's interesting about
this whole situation is you can imagine
what happens during a volcanic eruption
let me draw a volcano here so let's say
that this is our volcano
and it erupts at some time
in the past so it is it erupts and you
have all of this lava flowing
all of this lava and while the lava that
lava will contain some amount of
potassium 40 and actually it'll already
contain some amount of argon 40. it'll
already contain some amount of argon 40.
but what's neat about argon 40 is that
while it's lava while it's in this
liquid state so let's imagine
let's imagine this lava right over here
it's a bunch of stuff
it's a bunch of stuff right over here
but in that stuff it is going to have
i'll do i'll do the potassium 40 and let
me do it in a color that i haven't used
yet i'll do the potassium 40 in magenta
it'll have some potassium 40 in it
just not you know i'm maybe overdoing it
it's a very scarce isotope but it'll
have some potassium 40 in it and it
might already have some argon 40 in it
so it might have already have some argon
40 in it
just like that but argon 40 is a noble
gas it's not going to bond to anything
and while this lava is in a liquid state
it's going to be able to bubble out it's
going to be able to bubble out it'll
just float to the top it has no bonds
and it'll just
evaporate or just i shouldn't say
evaporate it'll just it'll just bubble
out essentially because it's not bonded
to anything and it's and so it'll just
it'll just seep out seep out while we
are in a liquid state and what's really
interesting about that is that when you
have these volcanic eruptions and
because this argon 40 is seeping out by
the time this by the time this this lava
has hardened into volcanic rock and i'll
do that let me do that volcanic rock in
a different color
by the time it has hardened into a
volcanic rock all of the argon 40 will
be gone it won't be there anymore and so
what's neat is this volcanic event the
fact that this rock has become liquid it
kind of resets the amount of argon 40
there so then you're only going to be
left with potassium 40 here
you're going to be left with potassium
40. and that's why the argon 40 is more
interesting because the calcium 40 won't
necessarily have seeped out and there
might have already been calcium 40 here
so it won't necessarily seep out but the
argon 40 will seep out so it kind of
resets it at the volcanic event resets
the amount of car argon 40. so at future
date
so right when the event happened you
shouldn't have any argon 40 right when
it when that when that lava actually you
know becomes solid and so if you if you
fast forward to some future date
and if you look at the sample let me
copy and paste it
so let me copy
and let me paste it so if you fast
forward to some future date if you fast
forward to some future date and you see
that there is some argon 40 there
you see that there is some argon 40 in
that sample
you know you know and you know this is
volcanic rock you know that it was due
to some previous volcanic event you know
that this argon 40 this argon 40 is from
decayed potassium 40.
it's from
decayed decayed potassium 40. and you
know that it has decayed since that
volcanic event because if it was there
before it would have seeped out so the
only way that this would have been able
to get trapped is if while it was liquid
it would seep out but once it's solid it
can get trapped inside the rock and so
you know that the only time this the
only way this argon 40 can exist there
is by decay from that potassium 40. so
you can look at the ratio so you know
for every one of these argon 40s you
know for one of for every one of these
argon 40s because it's only 11 percent
of of the decay products or argon 40.
for every one of those you must have had
you must have on the order of about nine
calcium 40s that came from
that that also decayed and so for every
one of these argon 40s you know
that there must have been 10 original
potassium 40s and so what you can do is
you can look at the ratio of the number
of potassium 40s there are today to the
number that there must have been based
on this evidence right over here to
actually date it and in the next video
i'll actually go through the
mathematical calculation to show you
that you can actually date it and the
reason this is really useful is you can
look at those ratios
and you know volcanic volcanic eruptions
aren't happening every day but if you
start looking over millions and millions
of years on that time scale they're
actually happening reasonably frequent
and so if you dig in the ground
and so let's dig in the ground so let's
say this is the ground right over here
and you dig enough
and you see a volcanic eruption you see
some volcanic
volcanic rock right over there and then
you dig even more there's another layer
of volcanic rock
right over there so this is another
layer of volcanic rock and let's say
that this one over here so they're all
going to have a certain amount of
potassium 40 in it
this is going to have some amount of
potassium 40 in it and then let's say
this one over here has more argon 40
this one has a little bit less and using
the math that we're going to do in the
next video let's say you're able to say
that this is using the half-life and
using the ratio of argon 40 that's left
versus what you are
using the ratio of the potassium 40 left
to what you know was there before you
say that this
this must have solidified 100 million
years ago
100 million years before the present and
you know that this layer right over here
solidified let's say you know it
solidified 150 million years before the
present and let's say you feel pretty
good this soil hasn't been dug up and
mixed or anything like that it looks
like it's been pretty untouched when you
when you look at these soil samples
right over here and let's say you see
some fossils let's see let's say you see
some fossils in here
then even though carbon 14 dating is
kind of useless
really when you get beyond 50 000 years
you see these fossils in between these
two periods it's a pretty good indicator
if you can assume that the soil hasn't
been dug around and mixed that this
fossil is between is between 100 million
and 150 million years old this event
happened then you have these fossils got
deposited
these animals died
or they lived and they died and then you
had this other volcanic event so it
allows you even though you're only
directly dating the volcanic rock it
allows you when you look at the layers
it allows you to relatively date things
in between those layers so it isn't just
about dating volcanic rock it allows us
to date things that are very very very
old and go way further back in time than
just carbon 14 dating